hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast the evolution of diverse
ubiquitous crests DNA viruses presented
by Siobhan Duffy associate professor
department of ecology evolution and
Natural Resources Rutgers University
I am Alexis Krause of leopards and I
will be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational regional events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want and anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the box that appears on
the screen our speaker or respond to
your questions via email if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming Siobhan Duffy I
will now turn the presentation over turn
hi everyone I'm here today to talk about
a group of viruses the circular ref and
coding single-stranded DNA viruses that
you might not have heard much about
before but we now understand are a very
diverse group that's present in almost
everywhere in the environment there are
many kinds of viruses there are
double-stranded DNA viruses like our own
genomes single-stranded DNA viruses
which I'm going to talk about today but
probably when most of you think about
viruses you think about RNA viruses
viruses that have diverse but RNA
genomes are common pathogens of humans
causing diseases like rabies influenza
rotavirus or HIV and these are the kinds
of viruses that humans care the most
about the ones that infect humans
themselves
you may be able to think of an example
of a double-stranded DNA virus for
example chickenpox but most people would
be hard-pressed to come up with an
example of a single-stranded DNA virus
the group of viruses I'm talking about
today are not going to be all of the
single-stranded DNA viruses but most of
them they'll be viruses that share a
number of traits in common I'm going to
be focusing on the circular rep encoding
single-stranded DNA viruses they have a
circular single-stranded DNA genome and
they all encode a homologous or the
replication associated protein the rep
is not a polymerase but it assists the
polymerase a--'s of the cells that these
viruses infect in replicating these
viral genomes we are knowing so much
more about Christine and viruses
especially the ones that infect
eukaryotes because of a
commercialization of a polymerase the
5:29 polymerase it's marketed as
template i or genome fee that does
rolling circle amplification of
templates it's proven very useful for
amplifying very long stretches of
eukaryotic genomes but it it
preferentially amplifies circular
single-stranded DNA meaning if there are
any crest DNA viruses in your medicine
example if you're using this polymerase
to do your meta genomic analysis you're
gonna get an over-representation of
christena viruses and such many people
have turned into inadvertent crest DNA
viral discoverers because of this and we
found Christina viruses basically
everywhere people have looked this is a
semi exhaustive search of the literature
of the last ten years looking at all of
the different locations where completely
novel species of Christine a viruses
have been found
this isn't including places where people
have used I've been looking for
Christina viruses and found novel
strains or novel types of viruses that
we already knew about these are places
where people found something that looks
very different than anything else we've
previously known and merited it
the measure of a different species well
I've colored in landmasses here the
Terra oceans project has been an
invaluable resource for finding novel
kress viruses we found crest DNA viruses
in Antarctica etc it appears that every
place we look we can find some perhaps
eventually will saturate the diversity
but we keep finding a lot of novelty as
we find more Christine eight viruses and
in fact while the last decade has been a
fantastic one for viral discovery all
around I argued that it's been the
decade of crest DNA viruses compared to
almost all other viral groups if you
look at the situation of how much we
knew about this group in 2011 at the
time of the ninth International
Committee of the taxonomy of viruses
report there are only three families
that represented crest DNA diversity all
of the animal infecting crustini viruses
were in family circle Verde and we were
sure that they infected mammals and
avian hosts and there were two groups of
highly unrelated groups of crustini
viruses that infected plants the Gemini
very day and the nano be renamed the
Gemini very day are segmented they can
have one or two genomic segments circle
viruses all have ones like them the Nano
viruses can have many segments ranging
from six to ten each each of them
individually encapsulated in their own
capsid shell if you compare the
diversity from 2011 well I have some
pictures here of the kinds of diseases
caused by a circle virus you can feather
disease on the top I have an example of
a Gemini virus causing mosaic disease
symptoms on an ornamental plant al butyl
on in the middle and the devastating
effects of the nanovirus banana bunchy
top virus are shown at the bottom that
is a full-grown bunch of bananas and
that's a 12-inch ruler so clearly these
diseases could have some substantial
economic impacts on the crops in which
they occur if you compare the diversity
that we had in 2011 to today we're in
the tenth ICTV report is still in
progress
we now have doubled the number of
families and have a net
number of five new Jenner and existing
families and we still haven't
systematized a great diversity of the
Christina viruses that have been
discovered in the last decade we have
diversified the range of hosts that we
know that can be infected by or
associated with crest DNA viruses I have
to say infected by or associated with
because we have very few examples of
some of these novel groups of viruses
where we have a host where we've been
able to fulfill Koch's postulates for
example we have a family genome OVA I
have a little fungal symbol there
there's a single well characterized
example from genomic DNA that infects
fungus everything else that's in that
family is associated to with that
species because of sequence similarity
all the black pluses there are where we
include a range of viruses have been
found in environments metagenomic
samples from sea water from grinding up
an animal where you could get viruses
that infect the animal could infect
something the animal just ate could
infect something in the holo biomes
of the animals perhaps the protozoa that
are living in association with the
animal so we're sure that the besaid not
doing the sope didn't have the everyday
in fact diatoms at least but they we
found them and many other in association
with many other different kinds of
eukaryotes the circle viruses we've now
expanded the versity of their host to
not just mammals and birds but fish
invertebrates both marine and
terrestrial and they've been found in
association with a whole lot of other
environments and hosts but we're not as
sure that they are infecting those so
it's the judoma bearding i mentioned one
infects a fungus who knows about the
others but we found them in a lot of
different environments and there's a
revolution here for the taxonomy of
viruses we have an officially
categorized family of crustini viruses
smack of e'r'day where we have no
cultured members where everything about
creation of this family is about a group
of similar sequences that have been
found in many different environments in
several different continents
and we don't have a definitive measure
of any of their hosts
so these viruses are there they're much
more diverse than we had a sense of ten
years ago and they're infecting hosts
that we don't necessarily we we don't
have a great handle on their host
diversity yeah the cause we know most
mostly about these viruses through their
sequences I'm gonna talk about three
related molecular evolution projects
that my lab has been working on trying
to understand the diversity of crustini
viruses first we're going to talk about
the nucleotide level genomic evolution
of some well studied single-stranded DNA
viruses this was part of the PhD thesis
of II miss ya she's now a postdoc
University of Washington both them then
I'm going to talk about our efforts to
create a phylogeny based on the
homologous repped protein that all of
these crustini viruses share this has
been part of the PhD work of Lilla chow
and then i'm going to talk about some
efforts that my lab has been putting
into how to classify novel kristina
viral genomes when all we have are are
their sequences to go on and to try to
do things that are complementary to
sequence similarity which is how we
typically identify novel virus sequences
we blast them and that's the work of a
postdoc in my lab eric laughington
and a graduate student alvin Crespo so
starting with humates project on
molecular evolution single-stranded DNA
viruses frequently have their bases
unpaired and hanging out in the
environment open this is a different
situation than what we see with
single-stranded RNA viruses I have a
model genome it's a solved structure of
an RNA virus the bacteriophage ms2 here
on the screen you're seeing lots of
stems and loops basically the
single-stranded RNA as much as possible
seemingly is trying to make itself into
double-stranded Paree
that's a much more stable configuration
for making sure the bases don't get
degraded and it can help the virus
package itself in an optimal way that's
not what we see with single-stranded DNA
viruses
I can't show you an analogous picture we
don't have any solve structures of
single-stranded DNA viruses in the same
manner but here is electron micrograph
from 1982 the two top circles are
porcine circle virus - which is an
animal infecting crest virus and below
it are the genomes of the
single-stranded DNA bacteriophage by X
174 and yes they've been prepared for
photography but they don't have the same
kind of tight single stranded binding
itself onto itself in all sorts of
regular ways that we see in SS DNA
viruses this is already by our system I
apologize and this is a quote from a
1991 paper I was looking at the
spectroscopy of single-stranded DNA
viruses when they're encapsulated inside
there when they're inside their capsules
ready to be transmitted to other hosts
the spectral signature of the vast
majority of SS DNA from the native
virion is that a melted ssdna
ie DNA lacking the ordered B form
backbone what this is basically saying
is that inside the capsid at least
single-stranded DNA viruses don't show a
lot of evidence for having regular
secondary structure that means that
their bases are more frequently unpaired
than on RNA viruses and it's an unusual
situation to have SS DNA durably
in situations because SS DNA is pretty
labile to chemical degradation the most
common kinds of damage that happens to
SS DNA are oxidative damages this
happens to our human DNA are frequently
transcribed genes undergo a lot of
oxidative damage in the manners which
I'm going to talk about oxidative damage
can target three of our four DNA bases I
there's all different kinds of
transitions or in one case a trans
version that can be encouraged by
oxidative damage but by far the most
common kind is cytosine becoming
deaminated into uracil eventually
leading to a c2 T transition this
happens all the time in our frequently
transcribed genes this happens in all
cellular genes that are frequently
transcribed and
life appears to have learned to cope
with this because all cells have an
enzyme called uracil and glycosylase
that goes around and repairs this exact
kind of damage when uracil which is not
supposed to be found in DNA it's found
it's repaired preferentially back to
cytosine because of the actions of a DNA
repair pathway starting with ung so CDU
deamination may be occurring to
single-stranded DNA viruses more often
than to most kinds of life especially
since single-stranded DNA viruses don't
appear to have access to you the host
repair enzymes like your assault and
glycosylase but it's not just that
oxidative damage might be pushing SS DNA
viruses to have this as a frequent
mutation there are also enzymes within
cells for example within mammals that
are part of our innate antiviral defense
mechanisms that act on single-stranded
DNA and can cause c d ug amination and
somatically the best-known group of
these enzymes would be the f of X family
they are responsible for hyper mutation
phenomena and HIV that occurs when HIV
is in its single stranded DNA state it's
single stranded DNA of HIV that's having
excited seems turn into your whistles
and so this could also these enzymatic
antiviral defense mechanisms also be
encouraging CDG emanation in SS DNA
viruses inside the host if Cu looks like
it's going to be a signal of a potential
mutation bias in single-stranded DNA we
asked whether or not we could detect
this mutational bias in the long term
evolution of these viruses would we see
a biased substitution pattern over
evolutionary time I'm going to show you
an example of how we did this analysis
using a crest DNA virus that infects
plants this is East African cassava
mosaic virus I have a little picture
there of its effects on a cassava plant
and the way we attract we attack this
project is to create out-group rooted
maximum-likelihood trees for whole
genome or for single genes when whole
genome information we're not was not
available this in this case has whole
genomes such that we would have all of
the genome
of interest available in GenBank at the
time of our analysis and we'd have a
sister group in this case it's in green
on the bottom of the screen
South African cassava mosaic virus
helping us try to figure out what the
route was of the phylogeny then we built
this tree using a the most complicated
kind of phylogenetic model that is
implemented in most programs which is
called general time reversible model it
allows every pair of substitutions to
have a different substitution rate occur
at a different rate faster or slower
than the other pairs of substitutions
that could occur but if you'll notice
all of these arrows are bi-directional
if a turns into T at a certain rate she
has to turn into a and the exact same
rate we then got rid of the ants s the
out-group in our analysis because all we
need the out-group forward to help us
route the tree as accurately as possible
and then from the potential theoretical
ancestor of the viral group we added up
all the substitutions that occurred over
evolutionary time through the phylogeny
we then used a chi-square test to
compare these observed numbers of
substitutions to what we'd expected if
our assumption used in tree building was
correct and for example a's turned into
T's at the T same rate the T's turn into
AIDS we'll then adjusting for nucleotide
frequencies of a NT we have a strong
sense of our expected number of
substitutions that could occur compared
to the actual number that we as we
tallied our results for East African
cassava mosaic fires are shown here on
the Left we have the ancestral base
across the top the base that it became
when the chi-squared value was
significant at a point O one level we've
shaded it in grey showing an
over-representation relative to
expectation and there are three kinds of
substitutions that were over-represented
in BAC MV g 2a c 2 T and T 2 G G de a
and C 2 T substitutions are what one
might expect from significant oxidative
damage these are both transitions
for g2a to be occurring so much more
often than a 2g that's is consistent
with oxidative damage same with CDT
compared to cheetah see we're not really
sure why t 2g would be elevated in this
particular in this particular Christina
virus as you'll see on coming slides
there are some idiosyncratic it was
substitution of representations that may
very well represent adaptive evolution
or odd effects of drift that have
occurred in these individual lineages
but I'm going to show you the same kinds
of results not just for EAC MV but for a
range of crest DNA viruses on the
upcoming slides I just want to also tell
you that while we see this in the long
term evolution of a CMV it's also
something that people have noticed in
the short term experimental evolution
stays they've conducted using a
different plant infecting crusty and a
virus tomato yellow leaf curl China
virus the group in China found that C 2
T and G to a transitions were dominant
in their lineages as opposed to T 2 C
and A to G transitions what we're seeing
this is a long term substitution pattern
other groups are finding that this is
occurring as in short evolutionary
periods of time as well this is not just
an artifact of a long term analysis so
here I'm showing you the
over-represented substitutions for a
range of single-stranded DNA viruses Phi
X 174 which is a bacteriophage then b19
and cannon parma virus are two linear SS
DNA viruses but all of the other viruses
here are crest DNA viruses porcine circa
myers to beacon feather disease virus
but in a buncha top nanovirus east
african cassava mosaic virus and ms and
may Street virus those are both Javanese
irises the first four rows are the
transitions the bottom eight rows are
trans versions and what should be
apparent here is that the most universal
substitution that we see across the SS
DNA viruses is that C is being turned in
so if I mean potentially due to
enzymatic deamination
if we compare these kinds of
over-represented substitutions from SS
DNA viruses to other groups of viruses
we can see how unique these levels of
biases are so here is the exact same
data I just showed you on the previous
slide I've just scrunched it up so that
I can show you additional viral genomic
architectures as well SS DNA viruses
here in black and then different genomic
architectures positive-sense
single-stranded RNA viruses so like
messenger RNA are shown in a bright blue
negative sense single-stranded RNA
viruses so the compliment to messenger
RNA are shown in a deal Brown is a
double-stranded DNA virus and then beige
is a double-stranded RNA virus all of
these groups of viruses even the
double-stranded ones show some kinds of
over-represented substitution biases we
see more transition biases than
transversion biases we think this is
solely due to the statistical power in
our analyses there are more transitions
that occur over evolutionary time that
are tolerated by selection over
evolutionary time so we're able to see
subtle differences in transition rates
in a way that's harder to do with less
frequently occurring trans versions the
second thing I would point out is that
while c2 t is by no means exclusive as a
bias for single-stranded DNA viruses SS
DNA viruses are the most consistent in
showing C 2 T transition biases across
all different genomic architectures and
the reason why it's important to talk
about these kinds of biases and long
term viral evolution for all groups but
especially the SS DNA viruses is that as
we talked about before we build our
trees using nucleotide substitution
models that assume that forwarding
reverse substitutions occur at the same
rate cytosines turn into thymines at the
same rate that findings turned into
cytosines if that were actually true
during viral evolution I wouldn't be
able to detect a CG overrepresentation
bias those bases would have turned back
into cytosines at some point in time so
because we know that the more accurate
our models for describing biological
Naumann on the more accurate our results
we have to have nucleotide substitution
models that can accommodate a bias if
she just turned into cheese more often
than the reverse we can't have this
double-headed arrow the general time
reversible model has so instead the most
complicated model the fully
parameterized nucleotide substitution
model that people knew theoretically
should exist in the back in the 1980s
and into the 1990s would be the
unrestricted model it's short name is
unrest this was proposed by C Hengyang I
he actually encoded not just the general
time reversible model but the ability to
run the unrest model into his program
panel which is still frequently used for
hypothesis testing and final genetics
but it's a very poor model for building
phylogenetic trees because I can't
handle building a tree with more than
say ten taxa back in the 90s he compared
the fit of the GTR model and the unrest
model to choose small datasets all from
mammals a one with six taxa one with
nine taxa and said you know the unrest
model doesn't really get you anything
better than the GTR model for these
small data sets with mammalian genes the
use of the unrestricted model does not
appear to be worthwhile and for a long
time that's been the last word on the
use of the unrestricted model but if we
can prove as we have the viruses have
statistically detectable substitution
biases it may be time to dust off the
unrestricted model encoded into some of
our modern phylogenetics programs and
use it to describe viral evolution as
accurately as possible
viral evolutionary phylogenies are
important because that's how we do
molecular epidemiology a lot of the time
and how we track outbreaks sometimes in
real time across countries that it's
invading to see whether or not the
unrestricted model would help us model
viral evolution better especially for
RSS DNA viruses we took the trees from
the previous analysis these out-group
rooted maximum-likelihood trees that
have been created with the general time
reversible model and we fit the unrest
model to them in pamel so we didn't
build the trees all over again
we took a tree bill
with GTR and said how much does unrest
make it better and is it worth all of
those extra parameters and our results
are shown here the change in al-qaida
keys information criterion is shown on
the y-axis across the x-axis we have our
five genomic architectures of viruses
that we're highlighting here black ssdna
blue positive-sense single-stranded RNA
teal negative single-stranded RNA brown
double-stranded DNA beige
double-stranded RNA the change not that
Yuki's information criterion if it's
positive it means the unrest model was a
better fit to the data than the GTR
model even though GTR was used to build
the trees we also have open and filled
diamonds here that's because we ran a
second statistical test which is a
likelihood ratio test because the GTR
can be considered a subset of the
unrestricted model we compared the fit
of of how improved the unrest model was
compared to the GTR using an LRT the
filled diamonds show a situations where
the unrest was still statistically
better despite penalization for extra
parameters you should see here that
single-stranded DNA viruses seem to have
some of the strongest benefits the
highest values for improved fit because
of the unrestricted model but unrest
overall was better for more than half of
our datasets this means that there's
clearly a reason to consider building
more complicated nucleotide substitution
models for people who work with all
different kinds of viruses not just the
most bias group which looks like it
could be these single-stranded DNA
viruses so I would all leave the
nucleotide evolution of single-stranded
DNA viruses for the moment now and go
instead to a higher level protein rule
of evolution amongst Crest DNA viruses
we have these biased patterns on a
nucleotide level does that mean - sure
that inform our way of building trees on
amino acid levels comparing proteins of
these diverse groups so if we want to
build a tree of life
life for our crostini viruses based on
their truly homologous replication
associated protein that's great but what
matrix should we use to build that trait
my student millage au surveyed the
literature from 2007 to 2010 to ask what
are other people building their crostini
rep trees with and overwhelmingly she
found that the two most popular models
here were in purple
Archie Rev that's reverse transcribing
element matrix it was created for retro
transcribing elements transposons HIV a
group of researchers who worked on this
kind of kind of viruses and retro
elements said we're having trouble
making our trees as accurate as possible
we need a specific matrix for our group
of biological entities because they
evolved a little bit differently their
patterns are a little bit different from
what we see in cellular life the most
popular was a general amino acid matrix
called LG the most modern of the general
amino acid matrices to be released it's
based on a huge data set but it's all
based on cellular protein evolution it
does not include any viral protein
evolution in this its massive training
dataset so what Lava tried to do was see
whether or not the Christian directory
would be improved by making a matrix
based on the evolution of the crest DNA
rep protein she did this by creating a
data set of over 900 rep sequences from
GenBank NCBI refseqs
were used only plus a few other
sequences that were created as part of
the grant that supported lillas work
this was assembling The Tree of Life
grant from the National Science
Foundation and our collaborators my
breitbart kirino's REO we're pulling up
all kinds of crazy new viral sequences
most of which have already been
published but we our data set includes a
few 18 unpublished rep sequences at this
time
but love then aligns them and built a
guide tree from the alignment in
addition to just purely aligning the
data set with muscles she's trimmed it
by over half of the sights using her
mail and using the most common tool for
determining what kind of amino acid
substitution matrix you're supposed to
use protest determines that the best
fitting data set for our alignment was
the VT matrix plus G and + F modifiers -
the amino acid substitutions she then
cut her dataset in half half of it was
used for training to improve upon
matrices and to build a unique matrix
that was designed to fit cress DNA virus
rep proteins
she used two different protein programs
to improve upon existing matrices fast
mg and hi-fi she used two different seed
matrices both the V T matrix because it
was selected by protests and the LG
matrix because it was the most common
matrix used in previous studies with
Crest DNA viruses she determined what
how often someone substitution would
turn into another from her improve data
sets and then tested the fit of those
matrices against a test data set the
other half of the data set so that one
what happened is that was making the new
matrix to fit the other half of data set
there was zero overlap between the
sequences used for the data fitting and
the data testing and then compared the
fit of the matrix using cone ml and Phi
ml she did this jackknifing ten times
creating 40 total different fit matrices
that were tested against ten different
test matrices tested alignments the
performance of these matrices are going
to be shown here we have our ten test
sets across the top the four
fish matrices that Lilla created FM g bt
FM g LG v dt fit LG and then three other
standard amino acid substitution
matrices that are T Rav LG and the PT
that were already discussed and here's a
summary of the likelihood results where
darker is a higher likelihood and
lighter color is a worse likelihood even
though the VG data set was chosen by
protests to be the best fitting for the
entire data set it was universally
terrible for fitting each of our test
data sets compared to other matrices
however our fits are individually
bespoke matrices were often extremely
good fits and the best fitting matrix
for each of the ten data sets are shown
in the darkest color one thing we were
very curious about at this point was how
different each of these 40 fit matrices
were from each other and here we're
showing the results of a Pearson
correlation of amino acid substitution
rates within the matrices to answer that
question for us you have at the top left
corner VTL G and Rt Rev our standard
already created amino acid substitution
matrices and then the 10 FM gbt fit
matrices the 10 FM GLG fit matrices and
then the 10 fit VT and 10 fit LG
matrices below it perfect correlation is
the darkest Brown the lightest color
here white stands for a correlation of
about point 8 and what was very
reassuring at this point is that all of
the matrices that were created with the
fmg method we're very similar to each
other it wasn't that ancient ville
training data set was giving us a very
different answer they were all circling
around the same kind of answer almost
any of the successful matrices would be
similar if we picked from here as it
happened we did a test to evaluate which
was the best fitting of the top matrices
from each of the training dataset from
each of the testing data sets and the
best data set overall describing all 10
training data sets was FM g dt 10 which
we have renamed
as the crest matrix and this is just a
visualization to show you in terms of
the size of the bubble how often certain
kinds of amino acids interchange with
each other
this is an unusual way of thinking about
how proteins evolved if you don't do a
lot of work with protein matrices this
probably won't make a lot of sense to
you but what's a nicer way to compare
this would be to compare the crest
matrix do some of those existing
matrices for example comparing crafts to
Rt Rev on the Left crest to the LG
matrix in the middle and comparing
across to the BT matrix on the right
when the crest substitution matrix had a
slower rate it's blue when it had a
higher rate it's brown so overall the
crest matrix is less prone to change
than the retro transcribing Archie Rev
model it's similar in scale to the LG
model with idiosyncratic differences
certain substitutions or favorite
certain substitutions less favorite and
it's in general higher than the VT
matrix which had been the best fit to
the entire data set used to start the
study we hadn't created trees using the
full aligned data set aligned and
trimmed data set using the LG matrix the
V T matrix and our new crest matrix I'm
showing you these results with their tax
colored as different tips blue so we
have read for Basildon of e'r'day yellow
for circle verde green for gemiini verde
a gray blue or green for jim of beer day
a bright blue for a bright light blue
for nano Verde a bright blue for smack
of arid a pink our in-class unclassified
so everything you say that's pink is not
yet brought into you one of the formal
groups in ictv or perhaps could
potentially found its own group someday
and purple our alpha satellites those
are not viruses they're molecules found
in association with some viral
infections press DNA viral infections
and while I'm not going to show you all
three trees all the time I'm going to
show you
all some results from all three trees
put onto this single tree which is the
tree created with the Christina matrix
this is a rapid bootstrapping rocks and
Mill tree the colors are just as I said
on the previous slide up at the top
right some of the conclusions we found
that worked across all three matrices
building the trees are that the
bootstrap support was primarily found at
the tips of the tree and not at the deep
branches of phylogeny very normal for
looking at protein evolution over a very
long period of evolutionary time however
we found some bootstrap supported events
or some events with very low bootstrap
support that were common across all
trees for instance all three of our
trees agree with something that's been
reported in the literature already the
family Namibia day it sits within the
purple alpha satellite so this is in the
bottom left corner of your screen this
family of viruses that are able to
replicate independently it's a multi
segmented multi-part tight family
I sits within a group of related viral
elements that are not themselves whole
viruses anymore that had very low
bootstrap support but this is a pattern
seen topologically in many people's
analyses something that we observed that
other people haven't seen before is that
all three of our trees based on our kind
of common alignment show that the family
genome of every day makes a monophyletic
group with some Germany viruses it's the
master viruses and a couple of the other
families of Germany very day that all
have an intron in their rep the genome
appeared I also have an intron in there
a so this is a very intriguing
possibility here that perhaps the intron
in the rep that creates the splice form
rep could have a single origin for
members of one family and all the
members of a second family and this is
the first time we've seen this kind of
association where the genomic var
monophyletic
but the Gemini VIII RNA are not we have
some of the Germany of everyday
during this monophyletic group with the
genome of here today we see that the
taxonomy of circle verde is going to get
more complicated circuit Varys
sir Kirby Rene is composed of two
generous circle virus and cycle of iris
they've and taxonomically revised just
in 2017 but they are placed all over the
tree we are not we're seeing that there
are some things that are still called
cerca veer circle viruses that are
probably going to have to be renamed or
other groups that are going to have to
be created to help describe this
diversity I should mention at this point
none of the crustini viruses are
assigned to a genus or family solely
based on their rep sequence and I'm only
looking at the rep sequence
relationships here in these trees but
we're seeing a huge amount of diversity
here one thing that our crest matrix did
that the other matrices that we use to
build trees the same data set didn't do
is we routinely saw that the red
Basildon muscle saladna be reading mark
group of ik and arvind Bersani are the
people to ask how to properly pronounce
this group more closely with another
family the smack of every day then we
see in the other trees there was one
smack of iris the dromedaries tool
associated smack of iris it's wrath
always grouped with the raps of the
saladna period a that's could be an
interesting evolutionary relationship
there but perhaps these groups are
closer together in general than some of
the other matrices would have led people
to believe most of the time when people
have been creating these kind of trees
to look at rap diversity they've been
focusing on how much we don't know this
is a figure from a 2017 Nature Reviews
microbiology article where the colored
branches are the well-characterized
named classified groups of crustini
viruses and all of the black diversity
the overwhelming majority of diversity
on the tree are from unclassified
sequences this could be one of the
reasons why some of the things that
we're observing in our crest
DNA rep only but all of the reps
analysis we're seeing some patterns
other people haven't seen before I
we're going to have to keep looking and
working with our our trees to figure out
what exactly is going on with the groups
we see that are intermingled is there
potential miss classification remember
the rep is not the sole determinant of
classification for what kind of genus
and family these groups should belong to
but has there been horizontal gene
transfer arvind Barsanti and mark Rubik
have a great paper that was out this
year because alaska's at all 2018 where
they look at horizontal gene transfer in
just the rep protein showing that the
two domains of rep have has significant
recombination amongst them not within
these groups but between these groups
and in the unclassified groups of
viruses because most of the versity of
crustini viruses are known only by
sequences this means that we have to
determine what genus and family a novel
sequence belongs to without having any
other clues than the sequence in front
of us
most of the classification is done on
percent nucleotide identity the there
are published cut-offs for a threshold
for a novel species published thresholds
for strain within a species and one
other important matter for determining
what group A virus sequence belongs to
is the genomic orientation many crustini
viruses are are what's called Amba sense
this is an example of a Namba sense
plant in fact increased DNA virus here
it has some Orff's in the complement of
the viral sense meaning that they are
ready to be transcribed into messenger
RNA as soon as the viral genome gets
into a cell but then there's also the
coat protein the capsid protein over on
the other genomic orientation on the
same genome it looks like messenger RNA
now the genome has to be replicated
before you can create a template that
the CP can be transcribed from whether
the rep is in sense or an tease
is one of the determinants to help you
classify what kind of genus your
sequence belongs to the other
determinant for what sense your genome
was in is the circle at the top of this
schematic and it's the origin of
replication for crustini viruses it is a
loop of typically a few more than nine
bases that contains a nine base sequence
that the retro team recognizes starts
rolling several replication up and can
Nick into single genome copies using its
end of nucleus domain I we used to think
that these non uh nucleotide sequences
were pretty invariant the sequence I I
have here was the invariant non
nucleotide sequences for whitefly
transmitted plant cress DNA viruses but
as we discovered more and more diverse
sequences the adherence the diversity
that we see within these Dada
nucleotides has grown to the point where
here are the universal codes for the non
uh nucleotide sequence for circle
viruses Gemini viruses genome of irises
and smackin viruses lots of ends and
ambiguous base calls in here as our
sense of how sure we should be about the
non a nucleotide as it arose we have
less and less faith that we can call the
genomic orientation of a viral sequence
solely based on finding one of these non
the nucleotide sequences you can imagine
a situation where you could find
potentially one on one orientation of
the genome and you could reverse
complement and find another so one of
the things we're working on is to try to
find complements to classification based
on percent nucleotide identity that can
help researchers feel more confident in
assigning their novel sequence to a
given a taxonomic group the first one of
these I'm going to talk about is a
machine learning project that's been run
by Eric laughington and the second one
is going is a still developing project
by a first-year graduate student my lab
Crespo to look at whether or not codon
bias can help us determine strand
orientation very briefly I want to
mention some of Eric laughing Tain's
results
he found that comparing three different
kinds of machine learning techniques
multinomial naive bayes classification a
support vector classifier with a linear
kernel and a support vector classifier
with a radial basis function as its
kernel all could be trained to do decent
classification on unaligned sequences of
the replication associated protein
either as nucleotides this is across the
excess of nucleotides nucleotide engrams
that is looking at single nucleotides
and dinucleotides than trying to cleat
is up to 12 in a row to see whether or
not we could find those patterns of
multimers would give us good
classification codons by the line to me
know acids amino acid engrams again
monomers 212 Murs and then finally
aligned amino acids and we can only look
at support vector classifier for this
aligned datasets the y-axis is a measure
of accuracy the macro average f1 score
and what you can see here is that
alignment doesn't help you that much
compared to using unaligned amino acids
and that immuno using amino acids or
conan's moving it to the level of
protein coding or protein improve the
accuracy of these methods compared to
just looking at the nucleotides to show
you an example of how we use the support
vector classifier for unaligned amino
acids to show that machine learning was
actually pretty good at catching the
assigning these things correctly to
taxon is that when we had a trained SVC
using 100% of our data set not using
jackknife training and test data sets as
the data that you're seeing here were
created with it was greater than 96%
accurate on assigning sequences to genus
our accuracy was initially impeded by
miss classification within GenBank
so we found some the same
stakes that others found and have tried
to fix when they've done taxonomic
revisions so here is an example of again
f1 score on the y-axis so showing you
accuracy of the machine learning tool
and then it's performance on members of
genus circa virus and members of genus
cyclo fires unaligned prep sequences in
March 2017 the model was very bad at
predicting cyclus it was actually the
one of the generator had the hardest
time with turns out many of the things
labeled cycle virus in GenBank were
inaccurate when the labels were fixed
some of them were called circle viruses
some of call cycle viruses accuracy went
up tremendously so clearly machine
learning is susceptible to garbage in
garbage out but with a well trained
classifier this is something that has
nothing to do with sequence similarity
in terms of alignment this is completely
independent of blast we can find
evidence and support for taking a novel
sequence and putting it into a certain
category in this complimentary way to
using blast identification finally
because we've already substantiated that
ssdna viruses have this cytosine defy
means substitution bias I'm going to
show you that that bias causes a strand
specific codon usage bias that we can
exploit to try to figure out what
genomic orientation of viral viral
genome is in so here we have that model
plant cress DNA virus here with our rep
and antisense and our CP in sense if CDT
substitutions are occurring on the
genome it's going to drive sites that
are less under less selection for
example the third positions of codons to
enrich for thymine in the coat protein
we're going to see NNC codons turn to
NNT codons not hurt the fitness of the
virus that much because they're calling
for the same of amino acid off and are a
very similar amino acid but we're going
to see the opposite pattern accumulating
in the red protein the thigh means in
the genomic rep anti sense protein are
going to turn into Phi means
those will call for the compliment
adenine in the codon bias of the
transcribed mr. RNA molecule this is
based on data from a paper from a
graduate student of mine from a few
years ago Daniel Stern Cardinal with a
couple of undergrads who work with him
he measured the relative synonymous
codon usage of 15 well sequence bakoma
viruses species these are plant
infecting crusts DNA viruses that all
infect dicots they all are infecting
hosts that have the same codon usage
bias which is slightly a chi wrench and
his results are shown here for the co
protein there was there are a number of
over-represented preferred codons many
of them do end in T for the replication
associated protein we don't see the same
pattern even though they're transcribed
at the same ribosomes if there were
selection to match the transfer RNA pool
of the host cell or the speed of
replication of the ribosome you'd expect
similar codon usage for both course we
see that mutational a bias pattern where
we have an enrichment for n na codons in
the replication associated protein
corresponding to an enrichment of TN n
codons in the virion sense so my student
alvin Crespo is taking this and in
Ambersons genomes he's using the hyper
geometric distribution to see which
Wharf is over-represented for TN n codon
use the hyper geometric distribution
says we're asking what's the probability
of seeing k carranza and T in this Wharf
before we get to the end of the orphe
and we're assuming that the tandem
codons are proportionately distributed
he adds up the number of Chandon codons
in the rep and the CP and then says if
the rep is 60% of that data set in the
cps 40% of the size of the Auris in that
data set then what's the probability
that we're going to see more than 60% of
the chanting codons in the rat before we
get to the end of breath for example and
he's seeing that he can very strongly
detect the
and holds for the vast majority of
members of these groups but we have a
couple of rogues that we can detect so
here is a different genus of Christina
virus cycle virus it's one of the
generate encircle your day it has the
same pattern as the plant infecting
crusty and a virus I showed you
previously where wrap as an antisense
and CP is incensed the p-values here are
the probability of getting 2 k CH anding
codons prior to the end of the protein
we're seeing that the vast majority of
cycle of our sequence is about 45 of
them correspond to this where our
p-value is very very strong and low for
the CP you're getting to the the tanding
codon some time and it's really really
terrible for the rep encoding sequences
because they're enriched for n na
they're not enriched for N and T you're
very rarely getting to the number of T
ending codons in time but we have a
couple of sequences that are misbehaving
and there's symmetric distribution -
they're misbehaving if because of the
way we're calculating the data if it's
more likely that the reps getting there
before the end of its protein then we're
seeing a terrible performance for the CP
and vice-versa these two sequences we've
looked at in some detail and they have
different stories so far the one on the
left clearly looks like this is a
flipped orientation cycle of virus I
that we can see the correct cycle virus
not a nucleotide pattern but only when
we flip the genome to be the opposite
sense so this looks like something that
was put into GenBank in the wrong
orientation it should be complemented
and the file should be updated
however the stronger evidence against it
being the correct orientation is found
in the example on the right and it's not
a nucleotide is definitely in the right
place but it's codon bias sees if it's
too wharfs look like it has the flipped
orientation this is something that we
haven't been able to find a satisfying
answer to this is from the limitations
of you in computational research and
that of being able to experimental e
probe these things my best guess at this
point is there could have been a recent
recombination event that flipped the
orientation of the Orff's such that
they're now newly in a cycle virus
orientation the sequence similarity are
clearly the cycle viruses so maybe the
non a nucleotide section was a product
of a recent recombination event I don't
know it would be wonderful to do an
experiment if you could get this kind of
sequence into culture it's not it's an
its associated with the bat it's not
grown in bat cells and to use
experimental pollution to see if it's
codon use changed over time as it was
being reared and continuing to grow in
this way but we can find some examples
that might be helping us correct the way
that viruses are input into GenBank or
it helped us expand the diversity and
our understanding of these general so
the project is working well I in terms
of comparing the data set from March
2017 and May of 2017 the same way that
Eric laughing - did this method alone
was able to find all but one of them is
classified cycle of viruses it could be
a useful method for helping people who
find crustini viruses that are and Amba
sense in terms of how to assign their
genome make sure that they're putting
their genome into GenBank and the likely
orientation but we also could be
expanding our understanding of what
these generate can do and maybe assign
having their sense that they're always a
hundred percent they've got to be in
this kind of genomic orientation might
be incorrect and as we know more about
viral diversity this method can help us
realize that the genomic orientation is
necessarily as sure of a way of
classifying the viruses as we might hope
to summarize I talked about a few of the
projects my last working on trying to
make sense of the diversity of
christiana viruses that are being
continually discovered and put into
GenBank single-stranded DNA viruses have
the strong side of seemed a thymine bias
that can affect many aspects of their
evolution on a nucleotide level
we found that Christina viruses on the
protein level they require a complex
evolution models both for nucleotide and
they need something more bespoke on the
protein level our Christina matrix was
the best fit by protest for the ref
genealogy once we were able to implement
it an encode it into protest so it's not
just the fact that we had created it
from portions of the data set and we
think oh that must make it good for the
data set using the same tools that
people use to figure out which matrix
they should run for their own data sets
grass matrix showed up as the best and
finally we are working on a couple of
blasts independent methods to help
classify novel sequences and they appear
to work as well as people examining
these things in depth they found the
same errors as were corrected in the
revisions to cerca Verde in 2017 we had
many people helping with this project I
want to thank especially our
collaborators on the NSF assembly a tree
of life grant my Breitbart and Karina
Rosario from University of South Florida
we had a number of people contributing
to the crest DNA protein matrix project
including movingly Eric Lavington little
Chow and Alvin Crespo are owned by
involved in all different aspects of
that project
he made an Stern Cardinal contributed to
two parts I discussed before in
molecular evolution of SST any viruses
their codon bias and characters Ari and
Lauren chakra bralla were students who
worked for a semester in my lab on the
codon usage bias project that eventually
became Alvin's hyper geometric
distribution project and so with that
I'd love to take questions
Thank You Siwon for that informative
presentation we will now start the Q&A
portion of the webinar and will address
some of the most commonly asked
questions by our viewers if you have any
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen and click the send button our
speaker will follow up with your
questions via email so let's get started
our first question is how important are
the crest DNA viruses in terms of
economic impact and causing disease so
some crustini viruses caused significant
economic impact but groups that we were
well aware of prior to the change in
sequencing technology that allowed us to
understand all this hidden diversity the
Gemini viruses the Nano viruses and
circle viruses are all big agricultural
pathogens the Germany viruses are the
biggest limit limitation to crop
production throughout the tropical and
subtropical world so they have
billion-dollar impacts in terms of
disease outside of agricultural settings
we realize there are a lot of diseases
we don't know the cause of and as people
are employing metamer omics as a way of
trying to figure out if they're any
viruses associated with diseased animals
or diseased plants we are going to
figure out that some cress DNA viruses
that we previously hadn't associated
with disease may very well be causing
some disease but they already have an
outsized economic impact and it could be
higher in the future as we understand
more and our next question is it seems
like there are more complicated unrest
model would improve the accuracy of
phylogenetic modeling for many types of
viruses why isn't this something that
viral excuse me that viral evolutionary
biologists tests for routinely the
reason why it hasn't been something that
people have tested for is a there are a
few reasons why number one
no modern phylogenetic software
implements it
I at this point a couple of widely used
phylogenetic software programs routinely
search for rooted tree space and if you
have if you don't have arrows going to
both directions and not bi-directional
they're only going one direction you
have to have a really good sense of
where your route is where your ancestor
is or the matrix doesn't make sense and
it can't help you model your tree the
bayesian methods Beast Rev phase these
could implement these kinds of
complicated models they just haven't
been implemented easily I have a lot of
hope that the RAM based project will do
so I
faster and easier to search unrooted
tree space which is what your you can do
if you have a bi-directional model and
it may not make a big difference for
cellular data sets and you know humans
are cellular we work mostly with things
that are bacteria other eukaryotes if it
doesn't affect their phylogeny as often
it hasn't been something that people
have been calling for viruses may be the
first group to truly need this to model
uh their biological accuracy maybe other
groups will figure out that there's
similar substitution biases that they
that their phylogeny could be improved
by modeling more carefully but because
the fields not been driven by viral
evolutionary biologists it hasn't been
something that people have implemented
into the commonly used programs and it
looks like we have time for one more
question
do you think that we have gotten a
handle on pressed viral diversity or is
there much more to be sequenced and
categorized well we definitely haven't
categorized it yet arguably there are
unclassified and uncharacterized
sequences associated with Christina
viruses by by their rep sequence
similarity about as many as much
diversity not classified as we have
classified so I think that the the tasks
of systemic izing of the group is fast
and untaek 'old it's it's not quite
tackled well yet at all
in terms of diversity I don't know when
we're going to see saturating levels of
diversity from sequencing projects
people are going out and pulling up
random samples from a lake random
samples from an odd animal you know in a
bug that no one's ever thought about
sequencing the viruses from before and
it gets ground up and we we pull
something novel out of it I'm not sure
I'd hope we've covered about 50% or more
of the diversity but I don't think we're
anywhere near saturation yet I think
there's still a lot of true diversity to
be discovered here I'd like to once
again thank Siobhan for her presentation
I would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing from
December of 2018 you will receive an
email from laberd's letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's event that's all for now thank
you for joining us and we hope to see
you again soon goodbye